dallas kykel on the hill on for his 20th
start looking for his eighth win is era
of 432 jose ramirez seven for 19. he
hits everybody well
one two change up slow it's 79 and
ramirez way out in front one two three
through cleveland goes dallas kykel
krista mckenzie gonna start for the
indians tonight kenzie has been pitching
much better lately in the month of july
he's only one but he has a 371 in era
and 17 innings just three walks and 18
strikeouts
and sheets swings and sends a little
floater into center racing out owen
miller gives way and ahmed rosario the
indian shortstop tracks it down good
first inning for trista mckenzie we are
scoreless after one brian goodwin steps
in now lefty
great shot this is a great shot good one
to right field bring him home
one-nothing socks here in the second
inning the fifth home run of the year
gets the socks on top brian goodwin
having all kinds of fun rounding the
bases on that solo shot sebby zavala
will dig in to start the bottom half of
the third sox up one nothing
in the air center field straw going back
at the track at the wall
and the first home run
in sebby zavala's career
bye bye lil sebastian two nothing socks
a towering fly ball over 400 feet away
from home plate
and miles straw runs out of room
ford home run replay it's a four-seam
fastball try to get it inside he
couldn't get it there so congrats to
semi
two home runs two run lead quart home
run replay
all is right with the world
how about that
that didn't just make it either that had
a little something extra and ahmed
rosario leads things off for the tribe
rosario bounced to third his first time
up
hammered hard deep left field goodbye
ahmed rosario with his sixth home run of
the year and a good at bat
he did not miss that pitch he tried to
go in with it he got the barrel head out
and creased it that's the same pitch
that uh ramirez hit so both hits coming
on the uh cutter the tribe is on the
board
also the home runs in this ball game
there's the cut
and look it stays middle of the plate
and there comes the barrel head to see
you later
you know you don't see him pull the ball
but there's a case where the pitcher
made a mistake slowed it down and he
ends up turning on it ahmed rosario puts
the indians on the board
sebi will really try and make it hurt
with the bases loaded two out on the
heels of his first career home run
two-and-oh
semi-zavala cranks this one to left
field ramirez back at the wall savvy
zavala one more time
this one's a slam
the night of a lifetime
for seve zavala
ten thousand candles in the wind six to
one
in the fourth inning i would say sebby's
pretty happy right now despite what he
looks like
you're talking about five runs batted in
already
early in the fourth inning
it's a five run lead
as sebby unloads on one
i took a look at ramirez in left field
he just pretty much gave it the token
look and realized that that one was long
gone one of the great things about it is
his teammates are as excited for him as
he is which is really something special
on a ball player two and two to miller
fourth stint with the indians this
season
live ball deep center back goes angle
still going back he's out of room it's
out of here
oh and miller has his first home run and
the indians get their second solo shot
of the night and it's now a 6-2 ball
game
well he goes straight away central how
about that
it's that breaking ball a little cutter
on the outside part of the plate or is
that a changeout
out there
it was a changeup he stayed back on he
got him earlier in the at-bat with that
pitch but not that time his uh first
home run now the indians are on the
board once again austin hedges will be
the batter the 1-1
swung on and there's a high blast deep
left field bleacher bound home run
hedges
oh my the indians are hitting some bombs
off of kykel
these last two innings
and now it's a six to three ball game
indians still trail but they creep
closer treadmill race here in july nine
home runs and 21 rbis the pitch
swung on a rocket to left base hit down
the line it goes toward the wall gets to
the wall into third rosario he's being
waved home and the throw goes off the
glove of the cutoff man tim anderson
into scores rosario fran mill reyes with
an rbi double it's a six to four ball
game well that's it for dallas kite and
now michael kopech there's a fastball
mcconnell hits it hard to left field and
it gets down and goes to the wall
molay scores and in the second base is
oscar mercado with a two out rbi double
to left field a tremendous at bat for
oscar now the set now the pitch
hence his line drive base hit to right
field mercado will try to score
goodwin's throw way up the third base
line
advancing to third base
is miller
and the indians tie it at six
oh what an at-bat by austin hedges these
last three at-bats have been about as
good as we've seen here no doubt
first ball swinging deep right field
good win back he's out of room he can't
make the play he can't find the ball
coming all the way around to score is
austin hedges after owen miller had
already touched home and into third base
with a two out two run triple is yu
chang
a five run six for the indians are you
kidding me that's unbelievable runners
at second and third only one out the
next offering
swung on line shot deep center angle
going back and sails over his head it'll
go all the way to the wall rosario
scores ramirez will score and into
second with a double is harold ramirez a
line drive two run double to straight
away center by harold ramirez it's a
10-6 tribe lead bala is having a career
day two home runs hasn't been in the big
leagues all that much but this is it
in the air right field mercado back at
the track at the wall it's a third one
sucks within three
two solos and a grand slam
not a bad night for the young man tying
run comes to the plate in the person of
jose abreu
[Applause]
what else will happen
on this field
in 2021 still a two indians lead the
former second round pick is ready here
it comes
slowed it down and struck him out to end
the unit and the indians lead chicago
10-8 after seven drive up 10-8 the pitch
swung on line drive toward the gap in
right center over reaching up making the
catches good one both will tag
chang scores from third straw advances
to third another terrific at bat by
ahmed rosario indians lead it eleven to
eight and with two down and a runner at
third jose ramirez switch hitter batting
left-handed ruiz comes set
and the 0-1
swung and ripped down the right field
line it's a fair ball and it'll bounce
out of play a ground rule double
scoring is straw 12 to eight indians sox
trail by four they'll be out goodwin on
first
two runs to four runs the two runs the
four runs and it's back to two runs
line drive rocket off the bat of adam
engel his first hit of the night how
about that line drive into the bull path
the socks seven eight and nine hitters
have cracked five home runs
hit in the head last night staying in
the game and now he comes up in a
situation to put
[Applause]
it's a one-run game
what is going on here welcome this man
greg kimbrough into the ball game for
the 40th time this year you can see the
numbers are absolutely brilliant he's
got harold ramirez and an o2 count
infield back swing to miss on a
curveball
strikeout number one for craig kimbrell
in a white sox uniform
one out away from getting his 13th save
and brian goodwin the batter
round ball first base euchain takes it
book it the indians beat the white sox
12-11.